[Musique]
bonjour Carole Gomez merci d'être avec
nous on vous a directrice de recherche
associé en géopolitique du sport à
l'iris et avec vous nous allons revenir
sur toute la controverse en torrent
cette coupe du monde de football au
Qatar qui démarre dans deux jours tout
ou presque a été dit certains dénonces
des hypocrites d'autres sont
profondément indignés l'événement à deux
jours de ce coup d'envoi vous quel est
votre analyse par rapport à ça est-ce
que déjà vous allez pas écouter la Coupe
du Monde
c'est une très bonne question et je vous
avoue que j'ai pas forcément encore pris
ma décision même si je pense que
beaucoup de choses intéressantes vont se
passer pendant cette coupe du monde
au-delà de l'aspect de l'aspect sportif
et donc en termes en tant que chercheuse
en géopolitique je vais je pense essayer
de regarder cette Coupe du Monde
toujours avec un oeil un peu toujours
critique pour voir ce qui va se passer
conformément à ce qui était annoncé et
aussi voir s'il va pas y avoir des
d'autres événements des prises de parole
politique
c'était rapprochement entre différents
pays ou des avancées sur certains sujets
donc
prise de parole politique justement ce
qui nous amène à la déclarations
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a deux jours il
ne faut pas politiser le sport à dire le
président français la question sur le
respect de l'environnement ou les droits
humains il faut se les poser au moment
du choix du lieu de l'événement et pas
après Emmanuel Macron toujours quand on
sait que le sport est politique par
essence est-ce qu'il a raison
à mon sens c'est une maladresse qu'il a
qu'il a pu dire qu'il a d'ailleurs
dont il a d'ailleurs dont il s'est
d'ailleurs
démenti automatiquement après en
expliquant à quel point c'était quelque
chose qui était important de prendre en
compte justement ces éléments de
éléments environnementaux respect des
droits humains donc ça montre à quel
point le sport porte un message
politique et il est d'ailleurs l'un des
peut-être pas l'un des premiers mais il
a été l'un au cours des dernières années
a le plus utilisé politiquement le sport
à défaire de politique intérieure à des
fins de politique extérieure et je pense
que là encore essayer de
continuer à affirmer que le sport est
apolitique que le sport doit rester en
dehors de la politique me semble
profondément faux voire même parfois un
peu dangereux puisque au contraire il
faut pleinement se saisir de ce sujet
regarder la réalité telle qu'elle est et
donc
agir en conséquence de cela la
Fédération internationale de football la
FIFA est sur cette même ligne d'art
politisation du football quelle est sa
responsabilité dans toutes ses
controverses alors pour être tout à fait
exact c'est ça qui est intéressant avec
la FIFA c'est que si elle prône la
politique du football et la prolitisme
du sport pour les fédérations et qui est
qu'elle nie a aux fédérations
du monde du football
tout rôle ou toute parole politique il
est toujours intéressant de noter que
elle-même n'hésite pas à se mettre en
scène sur un certain nombre de sujets
politiques le fait d'envoyer une lettre
à l'ensemble des fédérations qui
participent à la Coupe du monde en
appelant les joueurs à se concentrer sur
ce qui se passe le terrain à ne pas se
laisser emporter dans des idéologies
dans des dans des batailles idéologiques
ou politiques montrent aussi à quel
point elle est mal à l'aise à ce sujet
alors que dans un même temps Janine
fontino qui en début de semaine était au
G20 montre à quel point c'est une
organisation politique et il cherche à
avoir un message politique à porter un
message politique concernant sa
responsabilité en réalité sur la
situation aujourd'hui elle est elle est
pleine entière puisque c'est
par sa décision le 2 décembre 2010 avec
les 22 membres du comité exécutif que
cette désignation du Qatar a été a été
octroyé par 14 voix contre 8 et c'est
aussi ça qui me semble intéressant de
noter c'est que souvent on a tendance à
interroger les sportifs interroger les
fédérations interroger le Qatar sur la
situation alors qu'en réalité c'est
aussi la FIFA qui a pris cette décision
infinie et qui donc m'apparaît donc
peut-être pas responsable mais qui doit
apporter un certain nombre de réponses
sur ces sujets là Carl Gomez un ce qui
concerne l'équipe de France de football
elle promet de soutenir des ONG qui
œuvrent pour la protection des doigts
humains qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est une position équilibrée
ou au contraire c'est une façon
d'essayer de bien que mal de se donner
bonne conscience
ce qui va être intéressant à suivre
c'est voir plusieurs choses d'une part
la lettre qui a été communiquée par
l'équipe de France est relativement
large elle est relativement imprécise
elle ne mentionne pas une seule fois le
terme Cathare et elle ne mentionne pas
non plus les différentes ONG auxquelles
ils vont reverser un certain nombre de
primes donc il y a encore un peu de flou
sur sur cette sur cette logique là et
surtout ce qui me ce qui me semble
particulièrement intéressant c'est que
cette lettre là intervient à peine
quelques heures après la prise de parole
de Hugo Lloris concernant le brassard
non pas aux couleurs arc-en-ciel mais le
brassard one censé lutter contre toutes
les discriminations et pour lequel il
considérait que ça n'était pas pour lui
une bonne chose que de le qui ne qui ne
comptait pas le porter en tant que tel
et on se et à ce titre il suivait la
position de Noël le crête président de
la Fédération Française de Football donc
là encore on voit que les choses sont en
train de bouger il y a une prise de
conscience qui est en train un tout
petit pas de se mettre en oeuvre mais on
sent qu'il y a encore des hésitations
des allers-retours et des et des et il
sera très important de suivre cette
cette Coupe du Monde justement
avec ce regard là et voir aussi comment
est-ce que les choses évoluent dans les
prochains mois et dans les prochaines et
dans les prochaines années alors ce
n'est évidemment pas la première fois
qu'une compétition de cette nature
provoque pareil le fait de bouclier on
pense à la Coupe du monde en Argentine
en 1978 il y a eu les Jeux Olympiques en
Chine et tout ça et en quoi cette Coupe
du Monde au Qatar serait-elle
particulière s'agissant des doigts
humains
il y a plusieurs éléments de réponse qui
peuvent être donnés ici le premier c'est
lié à l'événement en tant que tel cette
désignation est intervenue en décembre
2010 ce qui peut donc dire qu'il s'était
il y a 12 ans ce qui à l'échelle du de
la façon dont l'actualité et donc un
certain nombre de sujets s'impose sur le
devant de la scène et considérable on le
voit la perception que l'on avait en
2010 est complètement différente de
celle qu'on avait aujourd'hui si la
question des droits humains la question
de l'environnement était évidemment
présente et un certain nombre d'OMG
était mobilisés sur le sujet dès 2010
aujourd'hui c'est un débat
dont on ne peut plus faire l'économie et
qui s'impose véritablement sur le sur le
sur le devant de la scène il y a aussi
un certain nombre de de
d'accumulation on va dire qu'il peut y
avoir sur ce sujet vous avez cité à très
juste titre la question des droits
humains la question de l'environnement
mais il y a aussi énormément d'autres
polémiques qui entourent la candid du
Qatar il y a un peu cette espèce de
sentiment de d'accumulation de de
difficultés autour de cette autour de
cette organisation qui fait que ce qui
pouvait être
accepté ou sur lequel on
le pris enfin l'aspect sportif prenait
le dessus lors des précédentes
compétitions on peut penser à Sotchi
2014 on peut penser à la Coupe du Monde
masculine de football en Russie en 2018
et Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques de
Pékin en 2022 là on est un peu
l'impression qu'il y a une accumulation
de différents éléments et le dernier
élément qui me semble important à
signaler c'est aussi la temporalité 2022
a été à bien des égards je pense un
élément une année un peu charnière
puisque je l'ai dit il y a eu ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2022 qui
ont vraiment beaucoup interpellé
notamment au regard des droits humains
mais aussi des enjeux environnementaux
et il y a aussi eu
en 2022 en septembre de catastrophes
naturelles extrêmement importantes des
rapports du GIEC de plus en plus
alarmiste et des prises de position de
la part de politique et de scientifiques
qui incite vraiment à la réaction et
donc je pense que c'est il y a eu une
espèce de conjonction de tous ces
éléments qui ont fait que aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui ne qui forcément
un dernier mot sur le Qatar Carl Gomez
le prince héritier a parlé d'un grand
test pour son pays qui dit-il
impressionne le monde parce qu'il a déjà
accompli et parce qu'il continue
d'accomplir quelle est la prochaine
étape à votre avis
alors la prochaine étape il y en a
plusieurs la première c'est vraiment de
réussir cette coupe du monde et c'est
vraiment l'enjeu majeur du comité
suprême de faire en sorte que cette
Coupe du Monde se passe bien se déroule
bien qu'il n'y ait pas de problème
d'organisation à la fois d'un point de
vue logistique mais aussi d'un point de
vue des gestion des flux des des
spectateurs le deuxième
échelon temporel ça va être la réussite
de la coupe de la Coupe d'Afrique de la
Coupe d'Asie des nations en juin
prochain dont la désignation est
intervenue il y a quelques il y a
quelques il y a quelques mois et le
dernier objectif qui apparaît en tout
type peu sur le plus long terme c'est on
le sait le Qatar veut organiser et veut
candidater les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques ils avaient présenté
différentes candidatures en 2016 2020 et
2032 elles n'ont pas été couronnées de
succès et on sait à quel point c'est
quelque chose qui tient aux yeux de
l'emira et donc il est vraisemblable de
voir potentiellement une une candidature
intervenir pour les pour les prochains
jeux olympiques et paralympiques d'été
merci beaucoup Carole Gomez pour ces
explications cet éclairage c'était notre
invité directrice de recherche associée
en géopolitique du sport à l'Iris merci
beaucoup